PROFESSOR: All right, lecture
19 is about mostly refolding,
common unfoldings of polyhedra,
convex polyhedra, and also
about Mozartkugel.
But most questions were
about the common unfolding
stuff, so let me
start with that.
First question-- is
this fractal unfolding
of regular tetrahedron
and the cube,
which looks like
this-- is it resolved?
The answer is no, but it
is at least published now.
This is at EuroCG.
One of the authors is
here, Ryuhei Uehara.
And it's still
conjecture, although there
is a way to explicitly
construct this.
This does actually
fold into two things.
It folds into a cube and a
tetramonohedron, a tetrahedron
with equal sides.
It's not a regular
tetrahedron, though,
but this is actually
an unfolding.
And they have another one, which
they haven't drawn because it
has 10 to the 180 edges or so,
but it is within 3 times 10
to the minus 1796 of regular.
So that's pretty good evidence
that this is gonna work out.
Let me write that down.
So they have a particular
iteration procedure.
It's not always guaranteed to
make a connected unfolding, is
the troubling part.
I think it will converge,
but the challenge
is to find an infinite
sequence of examples
like this one, that form
a connected polygon, that
would limit to the fractal.
They have that instance.
They have another instance
which is very, very good.
This is the error.
But we don't yet know
whether there are infinitely
many examples the converge all
the way to some fractal set.
So that is a state
of the fractal.
Next we have a
question about boxes.
When that lecture was
given, it was open
whether there was a common
unfolding of three boxes.
That problem is now solved.
There's two papers
about this topic.
The first one we wrote together.
And this is just
a fun example, not
yet related to the
three box problem,
but you may recall there
were some unfoldings of two
boxes where one was 45
degrees to the other.
This was the
challenge of making it
not 45 degrees, something else.
And here it's a 3 by 1
triangle that is the axis.
So you end up with root 10, root
of 3 squared plus 1 squared.
So that's still two boxes,
but at least at a funny angle.
And this was actually
found computationally,
with an integer linear
program for this.
Integer linear
programming-- set up
the problem of which pixels
are in and which pixels are out
in this representation,
and could you
fit-- we started with
these parameters.
You have to be very
careful about how
you choose the numbers to
make the surface areas match.
So we just chose that
by hand, and then tried
to find whether there
was such a thing.
You could formulate that as
an integer linear program.
It's not guaranteed
to be solvable
especially efficiently, but
this one we found a solution.
For fun we also turned it into
a puzzle, where we were just
modified the boundaries
in corresponding ways,
so now finding either folding
is actually pretty challenging.
Well, one of them's
probably easy,
but the off center
one is challenging.
But this paper also had
a first kind of solution
to the three box problem.
So this is one net-- it's
a grid unfolding, even--
and it folds into 1 by 1 by 5,
1 by 2 by 3, and 0 by 1 by 11.
So this is a flat box, a
doubly covered rectangle.
It's also not technically
a grid unfolding-- we're
cutting in the middle
of a pixel, here.
But if you just refine by 2
and call this 0 by 2 by 22,
2 by 4 by 6 and then
2 by 2 by 10, then
this is a grid unfolding.
I don't know if you care
whether it's a grid unfolding,
but you can make
it one if you want.
So this is the first
solution, and this is actually
found by computer search.
This came from a long
series of research
in the two box problem.
We started by looking at
all common unfoldings of 1
by 1 by 5, 1 by 2 by 3, and
then saw whether any of them
folded in to 0 by one by 11.
So the just for fun,
the way that search
was done-- which is
in the same paper--
is essentially to try to
construct incrementally
a common unfolding
of those two polygons
so they both have
surface area 22.
The idea is, you start
with a single pixel
and you say, oh, a single
pixel can fit on both surfaces.
Then you try all possible
ways to add a second pixel,
and make sure that at
all times the thing
you have is a partial
unfolding of both shapes.
So that way you
get to throw away
anything that's
guaranteed to be bad,
that won't fit on either shape.
And so as you grow your polygon,
you get more and more options.
So the max we get to
here is about 5 million
common partial
unfoldings of size 17.
And for comparison,
the total number
of ways to build
polyominals of size 17--
this is only looking
at grid unfoldings--
so all possible polyominals
of size 17 is 10 times that.
So we're getting a
lot of savings in time
by throwing away things that are
not common partial unfoldings.
And then, conveniently,
things start getting smaller.
You get to throw away
more and more stuff,
and you end up with only 2,263
common unfoldings of these two
shapes, top.
And surprisingly, exactly
one of them folds into a 0
by 1 by 11 box.
So this is unique for
these three parameters.
And unfortunately
that's kind of the limit
of how far we could easily
go with a computer search.
And we could maybe get
a little bit bigger,
but it seemed like
we were not going
to be able to find three
boxes just by computer search
if we wanted a non-flat example,
because numbers are just
going to have to get
bigger, and we're
not to be able to do this
enumeration procedure.
So we need to think,
instead of computer search.
Before we get to that,
one other fun result
we got from thinking is, if you
allow these flat doubly covered
rectangles, there's one
polygon, namely a long strip,
that will fold into arbitrarily
many distinct rectangles.
So if you take a long strip,
you can do this zigzag pattern.
In this case it's height 2, and
you alternate covered on top,
covered on the bottom, covered
on top, covered on the bottom,
and you turn around
and do the same.
And if provided your dimensions
are properly divisible,
this will make a doubly
covered rectangle of this size.
And you could also
do it with-- this
is height 1, height 2,
height 3, and so on.
In general , if you have and l
by one strip you can make about
l different rectangles,
depending on how you choose
your angle to be one
of some integer thing.
So that's cool.
If you allow doubly
covered things,
then you can actually
make many, many boxes.
If you really want
3D boxes, that's
where the next paper comes in.
So next paper is about three
different orthogonal boxes,
all not flat.
It's by Shirakawa
and Uehara again.
And here's one of the solutions.
So this one polygon is a grid
unfolding-- folds into a 7
by 8 by 14, a 2 by 4 by
43, and a 2 by 13 by 16.
And this is almost certainly
beyond what we could ever
do by computer search,
by just exhaustion.
This is found using human
intelligence, and this grid
pattern.
And they have another example.
This one falls into 2 by 13 by
58, 7 by 14 by 38, and 7 by 56.
This is actually-- this a
little more complicated,
or a little bigger,
I should say.
They're both based on a
common principle, which
is to start from a solution
to the two box problem
and then modify it
to make three boxes.
So this is a common unfolding
event a by b by 8a box,
and an a by two a
by 2a plus 3b box
for, I think, for any
values of a and b.
And essentially the way you
see that is, you either wrap it
around this way, or you
wrap it around this way.
I think that's how
the two foldings work.
You have to figure out which
of these lines to keep,
and which ones to throw.
I haven't color coded them here.
But that's a general
thing that's known before.
I think maybe we
even saw in lecture
this-- there was an example
where you could just repeat,
and get infinitely many
examples of two different boxes.
Now we want to modify it to
make three different boxes,
or to add a third box.
It's not known how to do a
fourth box of nonzero volume.
So the basic idea,
which doesn't work,
is following-- if
I built some box,
and I slit it in this
sort of h pattern,
and then I refold
it to be like this,
I should get a different box.
That would be really cool.
The problem is, if
you look at what
lengths have to
be equal for this.
So these two lengths end
up being these two lengths,
so those sums must be equal.
And over here that
same length must
equal the two
heights of the boxes.
That implies that actually
this length equals this length,
and so this is
actually a square.
It's drawn here magically
to not be squares,
but in fact they
must be squares,
so it's good example
of misleading figure.
Think about it as like, oh,
man, they have to be squares.
That means you're converting
a 2 by 1 rectangle to a 1
by 2 rectangle.
And that's really not
going to change anything.
You just rotated your
box, which is frustrating.
Fortunately, there's a
tweak to make it work.
The tweak is, you add wiggly
tabs and you refold things.
So this is a-- in terms of
the grid, here, we've got an 8
by 7 rectangle
originally on this face.
We do all these cuts
that are in bold,
and then when we refold we
also add in these dash creases.
That's kind of
part of the magic.
And we end up with
a 2 by 13 rectangle.
These don't even have
the same surface area.
Some of the material got
moved into the adjacent sides.
But if you stare
at it long enough,
this is a valid transformation
of an existing box.
Now, of course, the challenge
is to get this trick
to work with this
unfolding of two boxes.
And it'll be really
nice if you could
make it work for
both the boxes, then
you'd get four boxes, total.
We don't know how to do that.
But with this particular
augmentation--
so, same picture, particular
values of a and b chosen here,
but these extra tabs and
pockets are put in there.
Then we get a common
unfolding of three boxes.
And you can see from
the numbers here you've
got the 2 by 13 and
the 7 by 8 appearing,
And this comes from
the other folding.
So, pretty cool, right?
And the same gadget
is being used
in this the first
example I showed you,
which is a somewhat smaller one.
Again you get 7 by
8 here, and 2 by 13.
So, this is how we
know how to do boxes.
Now, in fact, there
are infinitely
many examples along these lines.
You can change that grid.
Parities have to be right and
maintain some proportions,
but there are lots of
examples of taking that grid,
applying it to this net, and
then you get these three boxes.
For any integer, k greater
or equal to zero will work.
And so you get a nice infinite
series of examples, I think.
The rough ratios are almost
the same, but-- is that right?
No, no, actually they're
changing the proportions.
You've got k, 4k, 16k, versus
4k, 4k, 7k, versus 4k, k, 4k.
So-- sorry?
Oh, 4k, 2k, and 24k,
sorry-- and this is 32.
Yeah, sorry.
I need to expand on that that.
So, pretty cool, and
this is the state
of the art of common unfoldings.
Next open problem is for
non-zero volume boxes.
Can you prove that 100 nonzero
volume boxes are impossible?
Who knows.
Maybe even four or
five is impossible.
It seems pretty tricky.
OK, I have one more
question, which
is about the smooth
unfolding stuff.
I call this a limit, and there's
this is issue about the area.
So I want to go into this.
Remember this picture-- we
take a smooth prismatoid, which
is two convex-- not
polygons, but two convex
bodies, parallel.
Take the convex hull.
You get the smooth surface.
And then we unfold
it in the volcano way
of taking every rib
here, every rule line,
and developing it out flat.
And when you do that,
you take the union
of the ribs and the
unfolding, does not
have the same area as
the original surface
area of the polyhedron,
which seems a little weird.
Sometimes we might call I
might have called this a limit.
It's not really a limit
of the discrete case.
And this is why we don't know
how to solve the discrete case,
and yet, we can solve
the smooth case.
The issue is, if you wanted
to form this structure
as a limit of
discrete prismatoids,
you want to subdivide this
into a very fine polygon,
subdivide this into
a very fine polygon,
and then try to unfold
those discreetly,
and then take the limit as
you take finer and finer,
closer and closer approximations
of the smooth things
as polygons.
It really depends how you
discretize-- maybe one way
to think about that
is, if I start here
and I do uniform spacing
from this point--
or I do it from this, point or
from this point-- each of those
is going to have a different--
it's going to capture
a somewhat different
discrete structure.
I think the way to
think about that
is, the gaps will be spread
out in different ways.
If I always cut here,
there will always
be a gap incident to that point,
whereas if I always cut here,
there will always be a gap
incident to this point,
and not necessarily
at this point.
Depending on your
discrete approximation,
you'll get a very
different unfolded diagram.
You're going to
get holes out here,
because when you do
the discrete thing,
the discrete thing
does preserve area.
And yet, you imagine, as
you take the limit somehow
the area jumps at the end.
That shouldn't happen for a
limit, so this is not a limit.
What happens is, you have
many different limit points
depending on your
discrete representation.
And this green
thing is essentially
the union of all
those limit points.
When you take the
union, the area goes up.
That's essentially
what's going on here.
That's my best interpretation.
But yeah, shouldn't
use the word limit.
OK that's it for
questions, unless there
are other questions
about this or anything
we talked about in lecture.
So the next topic I want to
talk about-- this is a bonus,
extra topic hasn't been
covered in this class before,
but I've always wanted to.
I think there was a final
project about it once.
It's this guy,
Theo Jansen, and he
builds these crazy
linkage structures.
And the next two classes are
about protein folding, which
is more on the linkage
folding aspect, and so
thought it'd be fun
to transition over.
Maybe first I'll
just show you some.
These are two kits you can
buy of his constructions.
This guy-- I will blow.
[BLOWS]
This guy's on here.
If I turn this guy,
he walks-- and walks
pretty elegantly if I
turn this very uniformly.
It's pretty cool.
It can walk both directions.
It's also unpowered.
You blow it, and it works.
Here's another example.
You see just the legs.
It's more clearly a linkage,
although this is actually
just implementing
the same linkage.
It's just got some thicker--
filled in some rigid triangles
here.
[BLOWS]
This is fun, because the
wind's going in one direction,
and the guy's going in
the opposite direction.
Here it's going in the
direction of the wind.
Here it's going
perpendicular to the wind.
[BLOWS]
A little bit slower, though.
I'll just manually
turn this guy.
Is he going a little faster?
So it's got really
cool leg mechanism.
Looks almost like an animal.
Theo calls these his
children, his animals.
His goal is for them
to be self sufficient
and to live on their
own in the beach.
How many people have
seen his TED Talk?
A few people.
You should watch it.
I'm not going to show it
here, because some people have
seen it.
He has this vision.
He makes them all out of PVC.
These are just injection molded
plastic kits which you can buy.
They're super cool.
Let me show you the bigger ones.
This is living on the beach.
At this point they're
not self sufficient,
he has to correct
them occasionally. .
But this guy's just walking
in the direction of the wind.
I think here the wind slows down
a little bit, so lose momentum,
then picks up.
He does this in the Netherlands.
He's got this crazy beach.
Here's a much bigger one.
It's got a lot more wind
collectors at the top.
So these are all self powered.
Originally he pushed them
along, but now they've
learned to move by themselves.
And very cool legs-- I want
to talk more about the leg
linkage, because that's
the more mathematical part.
So this is his original
drawing of the leg.
It's a pretty simple idea.
It's a pretty simple linkage.
You've got a quadrilateral
here, 4 bar linkage, C-K-J-B,
and you've got a rigid
triangle attached here.
Then another quadrilateral
here, and then a rigid triangle
at the bottom.
So it's really just
two quadrilaterals
connected by two
rigid triangles.
And so it's a one degree
of freedom mechanism.
As you flex this
quad, this one has
to adapt because that
quad controls all three
of these points because
of the rigid triangles,
and so the fourth
one is determined.
And then the crank is here.
So this says vaste printer,
which means fixed points.
So you've got these
two fixed points--
this is actually also fixed.
This is just an x to y ratio.
So these two guys are
pinned, and this guy
is rotating around this fixed
point-- that's the actuation,
and that causes this
quadrilateral to fold.
We are basically setting the
center of rotation of this guy
relative to this
guy by measuring
these lengths, a and l.
He has these numbers, which
he calls the 11 holy numbers.
It's a little cause because
there's actually 13 of them.
There are 11 edge
lengths, and then there's
these two, which are
not really edge lengths.
It's just a measurement of how
to put the center of rotation
relative to this guy.
And the reason why
x and y matter here
is because there's actually
a floor at the bottom,
and you have to orient yourself
correctly relative to the floor
so you can actually walk.
So he found these numbers
by genetic algorithm.
In the early days there
weren't-- I guess,
before there were a lot of
genetic algorithms around.
So he tried lots of
different values,
simulated them on
the computer, found
which ones walked
best, basically.
Ones that were walking well
in various kinds of terrain
would survive to
the next generation,
try various random
mutations, perturbing
all of these numbers, and
eventually finding this set
to be especially
good in simulation,
and that's what all of the
built linkages are based on.
This is his computer
drawing, plus some markings
on top of it.
If you take this linkage
and go through the one
degree of freedom,
this point, of course,
moves along a circle.
Then we're just drawing lots of
instances on top of each other.
The foot-- this
guy down here moves
in this pattern,
which is pretty cool.
This is basically lifting
your foot up off the ground,
pushing it down, and then
dragging along the floor.
That's how you walk,
if you think about it.
You push and propel
yourself forward.
So this scraping
along the floor,
if you've got a
high friction foot,
will actually move you forward.
In some sense, all of this
design-- and the one way
you would choose
these numbers-- is
to guarantee that
A- you get lift,
because if you have non-uniform
terrain, you want to walk.
He likes to call this mechanism
better than the wheel.
It's like every invention
of something like the wheel,
but even better because
wheels don't really
work if you have
steps on the ground.
Walking is superior,
cause you could
walk over bumps and steps
and things like that.
So you want a good
amount of lift,
and then you want a good
amount, and ideally-- you
can kind of see this here.
These are uniformly spaced
as you rotate around,
and these are all--
they look uniformly
spaced on the bottom,
which means you're applying
uniform force all along
the floor contact.
It's not uniform here, but
it's uniform down here, mostly.
It's not actually straight
in the true mechanism.
I think this is another
drawing, two other people's
drawings of the same mechanism.
Here the triangles
have been filled in
to be-- I think this is a
design for a metal version.
And then this is a
mathematical simulation.
Again, uniformly spaced
rotary cranking here.
You get to see the spacing
of the points here.
So it's moving a little
bit faster over the lift,
and then pushing down and
spending a fair amount of time
here, and pretty uniformly
applying . force.
Also not completely flat.
It looks like it's
convex-- in fact
there's a little
upward dip here.
But it's pretty good, pretty
straight, and a really good
walking mechanism, possibly
the best within this family.
Depends how you define
best, of course.
And here's a fun
animation of how
the parts of the linkage and
adding multiple legs, which
is I wanted to show it.
So you start with
one 4 bar mechanism.
These are probably not quite
the right lengths, but close.
You add two rigid
triangles it's a little
add another quadrilateral on
there you see the spitting
part offset relative to
that and then here you
get the trajectory of the foot.
And you see on a terrain how
it would move you forward,
especially if you have
multiple legs, then one of them
is always in contact so
you're moving forward.
And then if you want
to be even cooler,
you go to three dimensions,
use even more legs.
And you have a little
crank in the center that
offsets the timing of the feet
so they're all sporadically
moving, and that's
essentially what's
going on in this structure
where they're nicely,
evenly distributed.
There's a central
crank here that
just offsets the timing
of all these feet,
and it's super cool.
I mean, some ways
the coolest part
is how it looks like a
real animal walking--
the funny timing, and the
way you lift and then spend
most your time with a foot
on the ground, and so on.
So, fun stuff.
Let's see.
Of course, other
people have tried
to improve it in various ways.
There's a couple of papers
proposing alternate walking
linkage mechanisms.
This is the Theo
Jansen version, this
is another version by Ghassaei.
And it's actually a
simpler linkage, just
a 4 bar linkage over here too
rigid triangles and another 4
bar linkage.
I guess roughly the
same number of parts
but, I think, one fewer
edge if I counted correctly,
just because of the
way they're combined.
And some fun things as you get--
this is the foot pattern down
here, still has a nice straight
part, looks pretty uniform,
speeds up for the lift.
Does not lift as high-- this one
has a 30 percent higher step,
which is considered better.
You could move over
rougher terrain.
This one has other Jansen's
has other advantages,
like if you have two of
them in the same plane
they will not collide
with each other.
Two legs reflected
around each other.
This one, they would collide.
You have to move them
to separate planes.
But some fun things
here as you get
that this foot pattern is
symmetric, down the y-axis,
and you get much less
variation in the height,
sort of more uniform,
and a little less
velocity variation on the
stride part, the walking.
And then the other
thing, which I
think was the main
purpose of the design,
was that the center of
mass of the whole structure
doesn't move very much.
The blue dots here
are the center
of mass over the motion
of the Jansen mechanism.
And this one, the blue dots are
much smaller areas, 85% less
movement.
I'm not sure of the exact
definition of 85% there.
This should be, if you were
like riding on the thing,
you should feel less
wobble, in principle.
They did build one of these
out of PVC tubing as well,
but I haven't seen any video
so I don't know how it looks.
Be kind of neat to see
So this is a two fat
example, apparently.
Said this one was over eating,
and so it tends to fall over.
So it's a challenge to get
these things to work and you--
I can't imagine how many hours
he spends building these,
and then for one of
them to not live.
He does things like, he'll
run these experiments.
Like genetic algorithms
is one thing,
but he'll do the
real genetics thing
of building lots of
different variations,
put them on the sand, see
which one goes the fastest.
The other ones he kills.
The one who went was
the fastest survives
to the next generation.
But each experiment must
take hours and hours--
really impressive.
So there are issues in
getting these things to work,
and just having the leg
mechanism is one thing.
These guys have a lot of
very interesting mechanisms
beyond the legs, in order to--
they're sensors, essentially.
They're purely mechanical--
there's no electronics here
that are physical, I should say.
There are sensors to detect
things like the wind direction.
Recently we had the honor of
co-exhibiting with Theo Jansen.
So this is some of our curve
crease paper folding in this,
or some of his structures.
Some of these small kits and
photographs of his larger ones
were at this show in Stonybrook,
New York, earlier this year.
It's kind of fun.
And while we're on the
topic of kinetic sculpture,
I have to show Arthur Ganson.
It's funny, Ganson and
Jensen are so close.
This is our local kinetic
expert-- kinetic sculpture
expert.
These are four examples
I took from the web,
but all of these examples
and many, many more
at the MIT Museum.
If you haven't seen
his exhibit, you must.
He hand builds lots
of gears and cranks,
and uses them to
build crazy things.
This is called the
self-oiling machine.
it just grabbed a
bunch of oil and it'
about to pour all
that oil onto itself.
It's really gross.
There it goes, pour-- and
should never get rusty.
This is a very simple mechanism
that's just the random and cool
how the changes kind of
move, wiggles around.
It's a force to be
planar, essentially
because of that chain.
This one-- you've got various
handmade gears and so on,
and hand cut pieces of rough
paper, to make them fly.
And this is another beautiful,
relatively simple one.
You've got a big counterweight
to make this chair almost zero
weight, and then there's
a little cat here
that's just rigid and
going back and forth
and it causes that chair to
dance around in very cool ways.
It's pretty amazing.
He lives locally, and has made
a huge array of sculptures,
one which I don't have a video
of, which is a lot of fun,
is just-- there's a
big crank, and then
a series of like 20
to 1 gear reductions,
and at the other end
the turning element
is in a solid block of concrete.
And there's some
computation, like it'll
take 100,000 years before that
before it turns that concrete
around, which it can't do.
Initially the gears
are going pretty fast,
and then, slower
and slower, and then
you just can't see them
for like five iterations
and then it's
wedged into concrete
It's a fun, practical example--
practical Anyway, lots
of very cool kinetic sculpture
and all somehow based
around linkages although not
necessarily strictly following
our definition.
And next week we'll be
talking about protein folding.